er bildet ein loch zieht der leiche das
nachthemd aus und nimmt er da noch den
verlobungsring ab dann überschüttet er
die leiche mit lösch kalk den sparten
mit dem er das loch buddelt lässt er
zurück zuvor hatte christian f nach dem
perfekten mord gegoogelt
doch er bestreitet den mord an seiner
verlobten vor dem landgericht regensburg
christian f macht folgendes geständnis
als er am morgen des 26
mai 2012 aufwacht soll seine verlobte
blass ausgesehen und sich kalt angefühlt
haben ein puls konnte er nicht fühlen
nach dem besuch auf dem reiterhof seines
bruders habe seine verlobte über rücken
und magenschmerzen geklagt sie habe dann
einige tabletten aus seinem medikament
vorrat genommen ein gefühlschaos dazu
folgenden unglaublichen szenen geführt
haben
als christian epp seine verlobte findet
auf der kein rettungsdienst und keine
polizei aus angst dass die todesursache
rauskommt denn bei seiner arbeitsstelle
als krankenpfleger im bezirksklinikum
regensburg soll er regelmäßig
medikamente gestohlen haben
einen tag später soll er die leiche in
eine decke eingewickelt und in den
kofferraum gelegt haben laut christian f
beseitigt er dann die leiche im wald bei
bernhardswald mit einem spaten dieses
modell soll das loch gebuddelt haben
dann schreibt der marias familie effekt
facebook nachrichten um ein abtauchen
marias zu inszenieren maria baum us
leiche wird schließlich am 8 september
2013 werner 2 gefunden
christian f behauptet dass seine
verlobte an einer medikamentenüberdosis
gestorben sei allerdings wurden an ihrem
slip und in ihren haaren reste von ein
betäubungsmittel gefunden dass der
mutmaßliche mörder zuvor bei google
gesucht hat auch sein verhältnis zu
einer 19 jährigen patientin so nichts an
der liebe zu seiner verlobten geändert
haben die suche der perfekte mord bei
google hänge mit seiner leidenschaft zu
krimis zusammen bis heute bestreitet
christian f den mord an seiner verlobten
maria böhmer vor acht jahren mir jetzt
so gestaltet dass bild reporter jörg
völkerling jörg du beobachtet den
prozess für uns und du hast neue details
zu dem fall worum geht es dabei
es geht um ein ganz brisantes eine ganz
brisante aussage die ganz zum schluss
dieser halbstündigen erklärung von
seinem rechtsanwalt michael euler getan
wurde er hat sich ja in windelweichen
wurden bei der familie maria baumes
entschuldigt wofür der staatsanwalt ihn
noch gerügt hat das eine demütigung eine
pietätlose veranstaltung
und dann sagte der verteidiger christian
erfolge keine angaben darüber machen
welche personen ihm beim vortäuschen des
unfalltodes seiner von unten geholfen
hätte weil sonst die gefahr bestünde
dass diese person in der öffentlichkeit
ihr ansehen beschädigt würde
und das ist deshalb brisant weil in fünf
im laufe des verfahrens immer wieder die
rolle von familienmitgliedern von
christian problematisiert wurde
alle haben hier im prozess die aussage
verweigert es gibt aber sehr auffällige
indizien die schwester von maria baumann
zum beispiel geschildert wenige tage
nach dem verschwinden ihrer schwester
habe sich christian f an seinen bruder
zu hause angetroffen wie sie gerade eine
festplatte offenbar bereinigt hat nur
sich über den pc hermachten
und es geht ja um diesen garden feder
sparten der am leichenfundort gefunden
wurde christian f hatte ihn drei tage
vorher einen solchen typus gekauft in
einem gartenmarkt und als die gleiche
gefunden wurde wollte die kripo
überprüfen hat er diesen sparten dennoch
man hat sein haus auf den kopf gestellt
man fand ihn nicht und einige tage
später meldet sich auf einmal ein bruder
von christian 11 der kripo sagte doch
doch der sparte ist ja da zerbrochen in
einer wand verschalung kripo geht wieder
hin findet den spaten stellt aber fest
dieses modell ist erst lange nach maria
baumes verschwinden hergestellt wurden
und eine heimlich installierte
überwachungskamera am haus von maria
böhmer zeigte eben diesen bruder wie er
einen tag vor dem anruf bei der kripo
mit einem rucksack das haus betreten hat
alles sehr sehr merkwürdige umstände